Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Dienstabendärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das Erstgespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand guckt und jemand hilft mir.
Okay, so als werde ich ein paar Fragen zur Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwärten übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Karl Schubert.
Herr Schubert, können Sie Ihren für?
Schubert, Schubert ist von?
Okay, Schubert. Können Sie Ihren für Unternahmung bestabieren?
Ja, Karl ist ganz gut, K-A-R-L.
Okay.
Und Schubert, S-T-H-U-B-E-R-T.
Okay, Schubert. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt.
57.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4.12.67.
4.12. Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, das steht immer im Pass drin. 1.77 bin ich.
1.77, okay.
1.77, ja.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich gehe immer zu 79 kg.
79 kg, okay.
Wie heißen Sie Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Das ist Dr. Breitner.
Breitner.
Okay, Breitner mit E, Ende?
E-R am Ende.
Okay, Breitner, okay.
Herr Schubert, was für Sie heute sonst?
Wie kann ich Ihnen erlangen?
Also, wissen Sie, ich habe jetzt schon ein paar Tage,
also eigentlich schon immer wieder so in den letzten Monaten,
so Schmerzen gehabt, wenn ich die Treppe hochgelaufen bin,
dann hat das so ein paar Minuten angedauert.
Und jetzt vorhin, da habe ich mich überhaupt nicht angesträngt.
Ich bin keine Treppe gelaufen,
das sind ja Ferien im Augenblick, ich habe eigentlich gar nichts gemacht.
Und mit allem hatte ich so ganz heftigen Druck
und so drückende, dumpfe Schmerzen hier oben auf der Brust.
Und ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass mir total schlecht wird.
Das sind ganz heftige Schmerzen gewesen.
Mir ist mit einmal der Schweiß gelaufen
und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass mein Herz also ganz wild klopft.
Also, ich habe richtig ein bisschen Panik bekommen
und dann hat meine Frau mich schnell mitgenommen
und wir sind direkt hierher gekommen mit dem Auto.
Sie ist gefahren.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe eine Brust, seit einem Monat.
Nein, dass ich das immer mal wieder habe.
Das ist schon mehr als ein Monat, das ist schon drei Monate eigentlich.
Aber das ist immer wieder weggegangen.
Aber heute, jetzt ist es gar nicht weggegangen heute Mittag.
Hab ich sie jetzt bruschen lassen.
Jetzt ist es zum Glück weg.
Aber das war wirklich beängstigend.
Ich habe so geschwitzt und habe solche Angst gehabt.
Das war ganz schlimm.
Ja, okay.
Wie strahlend sind Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ob die irgendwo hinaus strahlen?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Nicht, nur Schmerzen.
Die sind hier so im oberen Brustbereich.
Aber sehr unangenehm, wirklich ganz heftige Schmerzen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie jetzt Schmerzen?
Nein, jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Jetzt habe ich nur so ein bisschen Panik, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, okay.
Ja, ich möchte fragen, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerzskala von einem See?
Ein, wobei ein sehr lachter See sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht.
Oh, das waren, jetzt würde ich sagen, sind die so bei drei
oder so etwas gerade so wahrnehmbar.
Aber das war, wie ich schon so, dass es mir Angst gemacht hat,
das war bei, ich stimme bei acht.
Acht, okay.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Jetzt ist mir eigentlich nicht schwindelig.
Und vorhin war mir eigentlich mehr übel, weniger schwindelig.
Mhm.
Haben Sie auch, oder hätten Sie auch erbrochen?
Nein, übergeben.
Nein, ich musste mich nicht übergeben.
Nein.
Okay.
Aber, war ist übel?
Mir war sehr übel.
Ja, also, ja.
Ja, so dieses Gefühl, das ein so, der speichelt im Mund zusammenläuft.
Kennen Sie das so, ja, das ist so kurz vor dem,
dass man erbrechen muss, ja.
Okay.
Herr Schubart.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden,
wie gesagt, die letzten Mal, diese, diese, in den drei Monaten,
war das schon so, dass ich eigentlich immer gedacht habe,
ja, Mensch, du müsstest mal zum Arzt gehen und so.
Aber dann war halt Schuljahrsende und dann waren Klausuren und Dach.
Und dann habe ich immer andere Sachen gedacht.
Und es war ja auch immer nur, wenn ich mich angestrengt habe, ja.
Und dann war es immer noch,
ich habe immer noch, ich habe immer noch,
ich habe mich angestrengt, ja.
Und es ist ja auch immer nach ein paar Minuten wieder besser geworden.
Aber heute habe ich das Gefühl gehabt,
es hat ewig lange gedauert, ja.
Und da ist mir wirklich ein bisschen, da habe ich Angst gehabt, ja.
Okay, wie lange hat diese Schmerzen gedauert, heute?
Boah, ich kann das gar nicht so einschätzen.
Es kam hier furchtbar lange vor.
Aber also bestimmt in halb,
halb, halb Stunde, dreiviert Stunde, ich kann es gar nicht genau sagen.
Okay, ist diese Schmerzen,
oder treten diese Schmerzen beim Bewegebung oder im Ruch her auch?
Jetzt ist das eben ein Ruhe aufgedreht.
Sonst normal, wenn ich mich angestrengt habe, habe ich da gesagt, ne?
Angestritten.
Aber jetzt, heute, ist es eigentlich so aus dem Nichts daraus.
Ich habe keinen Sport gemacht, bin keine Treppe,
schnell hochgefahren oder so.
Ja.
Herr Schubart, ich möchte diese Gespräche hier unterbrechen.
Und ich möchte Ihnen wieder mehr, wieder Parameter überprüfen.
Ich werde Ihnen Atemnot, Atemfrekanz und Herzrasen, Herzfrekanz
und Blutdruck, Fieber und Sauerstoffzettel überprüfen
und eine EKG schreiben.
Ja, das klingt vernünftig, ja.
Ja, bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Sie sind im Krankenhaus und guten Händen.
Ja, da habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass mich das jetzt so ein bisschen beruhigt,
dass ich jetzt bei Ihnen bin.
Ja, ich muss sicher sein.
Deshalb, nach der Untersuchung, wie können unsere Gespräche weitergehen?
Können wir unser Gespräch weiterführen?
Genau, ja, so machen wir das.
Okay, Herr Schubart, ich möchte eine Kursesunordnung machen.
Sie haben Schmerzen seit drei Monaten beim Bewerbungen, besonders.
Bei Belastung, nicht bei normaler Bewegung,
nur wenn ich mich anstrengen will.
Okay, aber Sie haben heute eine Schmerz in Ruhe
und es war, und Sie waren eine Stärke Schmerzen.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben Öbel.
Öbelkeit?
Ja, und haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe natürlich jetzt nicht gemessen,
aber Fieber fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Und ich habe eigentlich auch zurzeit keinen Infekt oder so.
Haben Sie nach Schweiß und der Schutteiproß?
Ja, ich habe es.
Ich habe es.
Haben Sie nach Schweiß und der Schutteiproß?
Also, jetzt eben, also nach Schwitze eigentlich nicht.
Aber jetzt eben, also als dieser komische Attacke da war,
da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass ich kalt und schweißig bin, ja.
Ich weiß, okay.
War sie ohnmächtig?
Nee, ich glaube, ich habe alles mitbekommen.
Also meine Frau, die war ja bei mir.
Und nee, das hätte die mir gesagt,
wenn ich zwischendurch ohnmächtig gewesen wäre.
Okay, haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstorben oder Herzklopfen?
Das habe ich Ihnen ja gesagt.
Ja, ja, ja, ich habe das Gefühl, also da war es ganz stark,
dass das so ganz heftig geklopft hat.
Und das habe ich jetzt eigentlich auch immer noch so ein bisschen,
dass ich das Gefühl habe, es klopft mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten oder Atemnot?
Nee, jetzt ja nicht mehr.
Also, Husten hatte ich auch überhaupt nicht.
Atemnot, ja, so ein bisschen dieses Gefühl,
dass mir halt jemand hier auf der Brust sitzt
und dass ich deswegen keine Luft kriege, ja.
Das hatte ich schon.
Okay.
Haben Sie Sotbrinnen, Blechungen oder Sauerstoßen?
Nee.
Nee, okay.
Nehmen wir einen Wagen, habe ich glaube ich nix, nee.
Mhm.
Wie viele Treppen können Sie beschwerden für die Steigen?
Normalerweise.
Also so richtig kritisch wird, so nach der zweiten Treppe, ja.
Zweite Treppe, okay.
Einige geht immer noch, aber wenn ich dann schnell hoch muss
oder wenn ich eine schwere Tasche habe oder so, ne?
Okay.
Ja, dann wird schon kritisch.
Haben Sie, fühlen Sie sich in letzter Zeit schweig
oder antreiblos?
Antreiblos nicht.
Also das hat mir schon die ganze Zeit immer so ein bisschen zu schaffen gemacht,
sodass ich nachts manchmal so beim Einschlafen
ein bisschen so Angstzustände hatte.
Das schon, ja.
Und also ich kann auch nicht so gut einschlafen.
Ich liege, ja, ich habe mich jetzt schon angewöhnt,
mein Bett so ein bisschen hochzustellen,
weil ich nicht so gut mehr flach schlafen kann.
Aber dann liege ich da in meinem Thronbett da
und habe das Gefühl, ja, hoffentlich passiert heute Nacht nichts so ungefähr.
Okay.
Sie benutzen, wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie?
Ich habe nur einen Küffner, aber ich kann mein Bett so ein bisschen
hochstehen, den Kopfteilen, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Schutteifrost?
Nein.
Nein, okay, sehr gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der ganz gut.
Aber heute würde ich jetzt nicht gerne viel essen.
Also heute ist mir eher nicht so nachessen zu muten.
Okay, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab- oder so genommen?
Nein, das ist eigentlich immer alles stabil.
Ich achte auch so ein bisschen auf gute Ernährung
und fasse auf, dass ich eben nicht zunehme, ja.
Okay.
Ist bei Ihnen irgendwelche grünische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, das, was alle haben.
Also vor zehn Jahren hat man mal festgestellt,
dass der Blutdruck ein bisschen hoch ist.
Und seit ihr nehm ich halt Tabletten
und das wird auch immer mal wieder kontrolliert.
Und mit Zeit lang habe ich dann auch selber regelmäßig kontrolliert
mit so einem kleinen Blutdruckmessgerät,
aber das mache ich nicht immer.
Das mache ich dann jetzt vielleicht noch so alle 14 Tage mal oder so.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Nebibolol und Walzacor.
Könnten Sie wiederholen sagen?
Nebibolol, das ist Nebibolol 5 und Walzacor 80.
Walzacor 80, okay.
Und dann nehme ich jeweils morgens eine Tablette.
Morgen, okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich war ich immer ganz gesund
und so nervt mich das natürlich auch jetzt mit diesen Schmerzen.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Nebibolol und Walzacor.
Noch etwas?
Nein, gar nichts.
Eigentlich nehme ich nie Medikamente.
Okay, sehr gut.
Brauchen Sie Herr Schubert?
Das kann man eigentlich gar nicht Rauchen nennen.
Ich rauche vielleicht so, ich hoffe immer, wenn ich mit den Kollegen zusammen Pause mache,
dann rauchen wir mal eine Zigarette.
Das sind so drei, vier Zigaretten am Tag.
Das ist so gut wie nix.
Okay, drei oder vier am Tag, okay.
Seid wann rauchen Sie?
Ach, das ist schon ewig.
Ich sage nicht im Beruf bin, das ist eigentlich nur so eine Tradition bei der Arbeit.
Ja, das ist jetzt schon seit 35 Jahren so wenig.
Okay, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke nicht regelmäßig Alkohol, aber manchmal abends zum Abendessen Bier
oder wenn man eingeladen ist, mal ein Glas Wein oder mein Schluck Sekt,
aber eigentlich ja, so vielleicht dreimal in der Woche,
dass man abends mal ein bisschen Alkohol trinkt.
Okay, dreimal abends.
Das ist eine ultimäßige Frage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht bei so.
Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, ich selber nicht, aber ich bin als Lehrer in der Schule,
da haben wir natürlich schon mal Drogenprobleme gehabt, ja.
Aber ich selber habe nie was genommen.
Ja, wie ist es denn?
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, das muss ich ja nun zugeben, dass ich das nicht mache,
weil ich ziemlich faul bin, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Familie krönchen Alkohol gang?
Beim Vater oder bei der Mutter gibt es in Ihrer?
Ja, tatsächlich, mein Vater hatte mit 80 im Herzinfarkt
und meine Mutter ist ganz schrill,
die ist gestorben bei einer Bypass-Operation.
Da war sie 75 Jahre alt, ja.
Und wir hatten eigentlich gehofft, dass alles wird gut, ne.
Aber da ist sie auf dem Tisch verstorben.
Es gab es irgendwelche Komplikationen in der...
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war ein zivilkind.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Schubert?
Ja, das, was man so als Kind eigentlich,
was alle so mehr oder weniger haben, mal die Mandeln rausgenommen.
Und dann habe ich auch den Blindarm herausbekommen,
der war angeblich entzündet, ja.
Okay.
Wann war diese Blindarm-Operation?
Ja, da war ich schon 18, das war so ums Abitur rum,
das passte gar nicht gut im Konzept, ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich bin Lehrer.
Lehrer, ja, Sie haben gesagt.
Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, genau.
Ja, meine Frau hat mich ja auch hergebracht zum Glück.
Ja.
Und die war auch bei mir zum Glück, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben eine erwachsene Tochter, aber die ist schon auch im Haus.
Okay.
Ist sie gesund?
Unsere Tochter, ja, ja, ja, die ist fit, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ja, logisch.
Als Lehrer musste man ja gegen Corona komplett geimpft werden.
Da führte ja gar kein Weg dran vorbei.
Und weil ich eben auch viel Kontakt mit den jungen Leuten habe,
lasse ich mich auch jedes Jahr gegen Grippe impfen und solche Sachen, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Ja, tatsächlich, also ich muss aufpassen.
So billiges Besteck und Metallknöpfe, ich habe eine Nickelallergie.
Nickelallergie.
Da habe ich so einen, so bei Hautkontakt,
wenn ich da intensiven Kontakt habe, dann,
dann kriege ich so rote Schuppe geblasen an den Händen, zum Beispiel.
Okay.
Halter Schlag.
Sie meinen Sie.
Ja, ja, ja, das wird so, das juckt und das rot und schuppe ich, ja.
Mhm.
Waren Sie in Lesse seit, im Ausland?
Nein, Urlaubsreise steht eigentlich noch bevor, ja.
Okay.
Hi, Schuback.
Vielen Dank für diese Informationen.
Ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas wünschen, Fügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich meine, jetzt haben Sie ja schon wenigstens das EKG gemacht.
Das scheint ja wohl nicht so ganz dramatisch zu sein, aber wie kann denn das kommen,
dass es mir heute so dreckig gegangen ist?
Das wüsste ich natürlich schon gerne und ich will natürlich auch wissen,
wenn das nochmal wieder passiert, was ich dann machen soll.
Ja, ich habe, ich kann Ihre Sorge und Ihre Angst nachvollziehen.
Aber machen Sie bitte keine Sorgen, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Ich will, dass Sie viele Ursachen haben und wir werden alle wichtige Untersuchungen durchführen.
So als werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann auch Wulet abnehmen und einige Labor-Parameter überprüfen.
Und dann ich will, dass Sie mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen,
sobald die Argymste vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen generell sagen.
Ja, das klingt doch nach einem guten Plan, ja.
Ja, okay. Bitte gehen Sie in den Mechanen oder bitte bleiben Sie in hier.
Ich möchte Sie gleich untersuchen, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, ja.
Ich werde gleich zu Ihnen kommen.
Gut, okay.
Danke schön.
Haarschaf in der Zeit, ja.
Ihr seid?
Ja.
Das ist auch drin, ja.
Ich habe noch Fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Keine Fragen?
Ja, wann genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen heute?
Ja, also das war am frühen Nachmittag.
Nachmittag.
Und haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, nein, ich bin dann gleich ins Kartenhaus gekommen.
Okay, danke schön.
Frau Oberarztin, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich. Wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Okay, der Patient heißt Karl Schubert, ist 57 Jahre alt,
ein Meter 70 groß und 79 kg schwer.
Herr Schubert, ich werde Sie heute bei uns wegen Zeit heute Nachmittag
in der Zeit, um die Schmerzen zu verhindern,
die sind plötzlich in Ruhe aufgetreten
und würde nicht in andere Körperteile austräumen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 3 von sie auf einer Schmerzskala,
aber früher liegt bei 8 von sie auf einer Schmerzskala.
Also da hat es starken Schmerzen.
Ja.
Der Patient berichtet, die Schmerzen seit vier Monaten,
besonders bei der Bewebung,
die Schmerzen sind ein Durukendechmerz,
der Patient berichtet über,
und der Patient berichtet, dass sie nicht flach liegen,
dass er nicht flach liegen kann.
Ja, er flach liegen kann, und er hat Angst.
Er hatte Angst, oder?
Ja, er hatte Angst.
Er hatte Angst,
und der Anamnese ist unerfällig,
bis auf Einschlafenstörungen.
Und seit heute,
in Appatenz,
Anvorerkrankungen,
seit zehn Jahren, Artillerie per Tony,
und Ernehmenebiloel,
5 mg,
und Wellsoca,
1 mg morgens ein.
Bei der Patientin, als Kind,
eine Tonselektomie durchgeführt wurden,
und im Alter von 10 Jahren,
wurde die Ernehmenebiloel
bei der Patientin eine Appanöctomy durchgeführt.
In der Familienanamnese
wurde angegeben,
ihre Vater hat einen Myokardialinfarkt
im Alter von 60 Jahren.
Seine Mutter ist an eine Herzkrankung verstorben,
und er hat keine Geschwister.
Er brachte eine Ernehmenebiloel
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Er brachte 3-4 Zigaretten am Tag seit 25 Jahren,
und er trinkt 3-mal Alkohol abends,
1 Fleischmia, 1 Glas Wein,
1 Zäckte,
1 Zäckte.
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Er arbeitet als Lehrer.
Er ist verheiratet und hat eine gesunde Tochter.
Er ist verständlich,
und er hat kleine Geschwister.
Er hat kleine Geschwister.
Er hat viele Geschwister.
Er hat eine gute Geschwister.
Er ist ein Erfälliger.
Ist die Schenanga, bündoten am Ehesten auf eine myocardial infarctus, myocardial infarctin.
Ist die fernsehre Diagnosen common lunginombolis, Artisection, Oda gastroesophageal reflex disease,
Krankheit, Krankheit in Betra.
Zur Abklarung der Becherverdien sollten die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Durchgeführt werden.
Zur Erste werden die Patienten körperlich unterzuführen.
Aber Sie haben eine Vitalparameter haben Sie schon öffnen.
Während der unsere Gespräche habe ich den Patienten mit der Vitalparameter überprüft und eine EKG verschiebt.
Aber ich möchte wiederholen.
Haben Sie auch schon Blut abgenommen?
Ja, in der Untersuchung muss ich abnehmen.
Aber ich werde Blut abnehmen und großes Blutbild, Entsündungparameter und Herzentzüme, Troponyl CKMB
und Blutgasanalyse, Neuron und Lebewerte und Elektrolyse bestimmen lassen.
Bei der operativen Untersuchung.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautveränderungen vorhanden sind.
Wo ist es mit ihr?
Sianose oder kalte Schweiß, kalte Haut.
Und ich aus Kulturen auch Herst und Lunge auch Abdomen.
Und ich beurteile die Allgemeinsustand der Patienten.
Und dann gucken Sie noch?
Ja, Allgemeinsustand der Patient kann die Spine oder die Hydratation.
Ja, und ja.
Ich gucken Sie auch nach den Füßen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich beurteile, ich untersuche bei der Beine, bei der Schwörung.
Bei der Schwörung, darum geht es, ob die Beine mit der Beine da sind.
Ja, bei der Beine.
Dann ich, bei der weitere Untersuchung, würde ich eine Eka-G schreiben.
Und natürlich eine Ekokardiografie, die veranlasst.
Was ist denn, wenn sich Ihr Verdacht bestätigt?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose, sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
schlage ich die Folgenden Therapie vor.
Zuerst werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen,
wenn wir uns einen Zugang legen.
Sehr gut, ja.
Dann zuerst werde ich eine Schmerzmittel verabrauchen.
Eine Trombolitis oder eine Heparin.
Ja, das kommt ja auch.
Heparin und Klopidograil verabrauchen.
Und ich möchte diese Patienten engmischig überwachen.
Engmischig überwachen, ja, da kommt also ins Monitoring?
Ja, Monitoring.
Und ich werde eine kardiologisches Konzil anfordern.
Dann natürlich gebe ich Zauberstoff und Nitrate und Acetyl-Salice.
Beginnen oder beginnen.
Ich würde eine Corona-Ageografie planen, um die meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen
und die Behandlung gleichzeitig eine Therapie zu machen.
Mit Stemz?
Ja, mit Stemz oder Barber.
Oder erst mal Lüse und Stemz, ja.
Okay, jetzt hoffen wir, dass das dem Herrn Schubert schon bald besser geht.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch nicht ganz so dramatisch, dass er jetzt nur so eine Attacke hatte,
aber das ist noch gar nicht so schlimm, aber es klingt schon ein bisschen bedrohlich.
Und dann warten wir mal ab, wie jetzt ihre Laborergebnisse und auch die Untersuchungsergebnisse sind.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf alle Fälle auf dem Laub und dann, ne?
Okay, okay, danke schön.
Ja, wir haben wieder eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht, haben auch schön und komplett vollständig berichtet.
Ich habe eigentlich, ja, ich habe zwei Sachen.
Einmal bei den Zahlen, müssen wir ein bisschen aufpassen.
Der Vater hatte sein Herzinfarkt nicht mit 60, sondern mit 80.
80?
Ja, ich schreibe ab.
Und er hat auch gesagt, er raucht seit 35 Jahren.
Und nicht seit 25 Jahren.
Das ist zwar jetzt bei der Menge Zigaretten, die da raucht jetzt nicht so ein entscheidendes Ding,
es gibt zehn Jahre mehr, aber ja, wollen wir dann einfach mal bei der Ordnung bleiben.
Dann ist mir, ach so, genau, sie haben ihn auch 15 cm kleiner gemacht.
Er hat gesagt, er ist 177 groß und sie haben ihm nur 172 zugestanden.
Ja, okay.
Ich schreibe richtig, aber falsch sage.
Ja, okay, gut.
Sie machen so ein paar klassische Grammatikfehler.
Ein paar habe ich auch wieder so während der Fahrt jetzt korrigiert.
Einer der typischen Fehler, den ganz, ganz, ganz viele machen.
Ich habe das eben hier aufgeregt.
Und natürlich, ich gebe Sauerstoff und Nitro.
Natürlich gebe ich.
Es steht immer noch das Verb an zweiter Stelle, auch wenn das so schwer zu ertragen ist.
Ich weiß, dass das total schwer ist und dass einem das total gegen den Strich geht.
Aber für unsere Ohren klingt es einfach so, so ungewohnt.
Ich weiß diese ganzen Regeln selber erst seit ich Deutsch unterrichte.
Und mit ausländischen Mitbürger Deutsch unterrichtsmacher.
Ich habe das früher intuitiv immer richtig gemacht.
Aber es ist wirklich so.
Und dann ich, nein, und dann gehe ich und dann mache ich.
Gut.
Und auch eine hübsche Sache.
Auskultieren.
Ein trennbares Verb.
Und dann kultiere ich aus.
Ja, das ist ein trennbares Verb.
Immer dann, wenn der, wenn die erste Silbe betont werden kann.
Okay, dann ist das Verb trennbar.
Also dann kultiere ich den Torax Raum aus und kultiere das Herz aus.
Ja, so.
Das ist so viel nur zur Grammatik.
Ja, ansonsten ein bisschen.
Haben wir immer noch drin, haben sie gemerkt.
Ja.
Und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen, gibt es inhaltlich und formal eigentlich nichts.
Wo man jetzt viel verbessern könnte oder dran kritisieren könnte.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht.
Also, sie haben vollständig gefragt.
Ich habe gehört, dass sie zwischendurch mal so versucht haben,
von dem haben sie wegzukommen.
Es ist nicht so ganz geglückt und nicht so durchgängig.
Aber immerhin ein paar Versuche gab es.
Ich finde es schon ganz schön.
Und natürlich war ich sehr erleichtert.
Ich hatte schon gedacht, sie zieht die Befragung bis zum Schluss durch.
Nein, natürlich war das Gold richtig, die Befragung zu unterbrechen
und erst die körperliche Untersuchung zu machen.
Und das ist natürlich der Murks.
Das ist ja so ein klassischer Fall, der immer wieder in der Prüfung dran kommt.
Aber natürlich ist es,
ganz untypisch, dass jemand in so einer Situation von A bis Z überhaupt befragt.
Da ist ja eigentlich bekanntermaßen schnelles Handeln erforderlich.
Und da kommt schon jemand an und die sagt, da sagt jemand was von retroschrenalen Schmerzen.
Da gehen ja schon überall die Lampen an und der wird ja sofort in einen Schockraum gebracht
und er wird geguckt und was weiß ich ja.
Da ist die Prüfungssituation und noch viel mehr die Simulationssituation hier jetzt über Bildschirm
natürlich völlig untypisch.
Aber das sind tatsächlich Erfälle, die ziemlich häufig kommen
und mit denen sie in der Prüfung möglicherweise konfrontiert werden,
insofern müssen wir die auch immer machen.
Aber mir gefallen die eigentlich gar nicht so gut,
weil es eigentlich ja unlogisch ist, dass man fragt
und das ist für sich, wenn Sie das EKG machen,
dann sehen Sie ja, wie diese Patienten jetzt,
hat ja eine erhöhte Frequenz oder hat ja eine schlechte Sauerstoffsetigung,
braucht er jetzt schon etwas auf die Nase oder nicht.
Und man würde ihn wahrscheinlich auch sofort schon gleich in Zugang legen,
wenn er praktisch reinkommt.
Also insofern haben wir eine untypische Situation,
aber Sie haben das ja super gemeistert
und haben gesagt, ja, ich habe den, wir unterbrechen jetzt
und ich untersuch Sie eben erst.
Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
wird eigentlich auch sofort tropon abgenommen.
Das ist ja eigentlich immer das Erste
und dann hängen die Leute noch so lange rum,
bis das Laborergebnis endlich kommt.
Ja, sehr gut.
Gut, also ich denke, da gibt es nicht viel dran zu verbessern.
Wie gesagt, passen Sie ein bisschen auf bei den Zahlen?
Ah, ja, ich habe einmal das schon gesagt.
Bewegung als solches ist ja etwas anderes als Belastung.
Belastung?
Ja, wenn ich gerade laufe, wenn ich tanze, was auch ist,
wenn ich mich moderat bewege, ist es ja etwas anderes
als wenn ich drei Treppen hochlaufe.
Ja, und das war jetzt ja so, dass der Patient erklärt hat,
er hatte die Schmerzen früher beim Treppenlaufen.
Ja, oder wenn er sich stark angestrinkt hat,
wenn er zusätzlich noch eine schwere Tasche getragen hat.
Und das ist etwas anderes als Bewegung.
Das sollte man so ein bisschen auseinanderhalten.
Und das wäre vielleicht, das ist noch so ein Stichwort,
da habe ich gerade entdeckt auf meinem Schmierzettel,
was ich mir noch notiert habe.
Ja?
Okay, ja, ich weiß.
Gut.
Ja, dann.
Darf ich Ihnen allen nur einen sehr entspannenden Abend wünschen.
Lassen Sie sich gut gehen.
Wir sehen uns übermorgen, wenn nichts dazwischen kommt.
Ja, gerne.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Rückmeldung und diese Unterricht.
Es war sehr schön.
Ich grüße Ihnen, Frau Kollegin, Sie haben gut geschlagen.
Ja, Sie haben gut geschlagen, kann man sagen.
Ja, gut.